Tesla's model 3 is arguably the
company's most important vehicle yet the
new car which won't launch fully until
next year at the earliest will be priced
more for the mass market than Tesla's
luxury models but with mass market comes
mass competition
Tesla's success to date and tightening
fuel efficiency standards mean
competitors like GM and BMW are working
hard to catch up just five years ago
there were only four electric models in
the US by the end of next year
there are expected to be almost 60 as
any car dealer knows the more rivals
you're up against the harder it is to
make the sale and the more you have to
spend to promote market and jazz up the
product this uses up a lot of cash and
Tesla already burns a ton of it worse
those competitors have won big edge on
Tesla they sell millions of regular cars
and trucks to absorb the losses made on
perfecting their own model three
challengers all of which is a problem
for investors paying top dollar for
Tesla shares Tesla right now is valued
at thirty billion dollars putting it in
the top 10 car makers in the world but
its sales don't come close to matching
those other companies take a look you
can't even see them here to buy the
stock at this price you have to believe
Tesla can both change the global car
market and beat everyone else while it
does so the model 3 will have to move
fast to catch up with Tesla's investors